is everybody ready we are 12.83 let's
try to get to 13.50 today
uh and now we're beginning to get to a
pretty reasonable level let's do it
okay 1400 that is our first 1400 that we
are facing
let me just close chess space one sec so
my computer doesn't freeze
all right so no need to change any open
okay so he's playing the philidor
we know how to respond to the philidor
uh we open up the center
thank you bearded harry selden okay so
uh in this position how do we develop
our pieces what do we do and there is a
little trap here that
well scratch that off the record uh in
the meantime can somebody tell me how
should we continue the development of
our pieces
where do our bishops belong is really
what i'm asking because our nights are
already developed
so bishop c4 is the move that we know we
want to play now
one pro tip in these kinds of positions
there is this idea that black has
of capturing on e4 and when we capture
the knight he goes d5 and he wins back
the piece
how do we avoid that without weakening
any of our other pieces like i don't
want to play f3 because
i just don't like playing f3 so one
thing that you can often do
as potato for president is saying is go
bishop b3
and talk the bishop away safe and no
longer do we have knight takes before we
can proceed with our development in
castle
he's probably going to go b5 not too
scary
okay so um there's a couple of things
that we can do but
uh let's not rediscover the wheel let's
continue our development
and how can we do that bishop
well bishop f4 kind of stares at the i
like rookie one
i love rookie one but there's one
problem
he's threatening c5 he is threatening to
win our bishop we didn't ask ourselves
what he
what he wants right he wants to go c5
and c4
and win our bishop how do we defend
against that
what do we do are we screwed
a3 is possible but a little bit too
passive and i'll talk about this
moment at length after the game the move
that i'm going to play is bishop out to
d5
and i will explain the hell out of this
move after the game
this is a very important moment actually
very instruct now what do we take with
we can take with either piece
taking with a pawn uh establishes a
potential
for uh potential outpost on c6 taking
with the knight
lands the knight on a very nice central
square it's a matter of taste but i like
playing with pieces so let's take with
the knight
all right there should be seven now what
i notice here is that our pieces are
very nicely centralized
so i'm already thinking in the direction
of how can i attack
even further and the movement should be
seven contains a hidden drawback
the bishop relinquishes its control over
one particular square which square is
that
bingo good job dr lonno and guess what
this queen is going to come out to g4
and we are going to start harassing him
along that g file let's get out to g4
now a good player would go king h8 here
in order to escape the pin
all right he does this i will take back
now our pawn is sort of hanging over his
position
all right what do we do here how do we
proceed yeah bishop h6 is good but he
does have a defense to that let's see if
he finds it
the defense is 95 in knight g6
um and he intercepts our control over
the g file
we'll still have a good position i mean
we'll still have a long-lasting attack
uh for the most part but again we've
played some very underrated folks
so i'm quite impressed okay g6 and he
doesn't find it he gives up the exchange
uh and he's going to be in very big
trouble he's just down a full exchange
now here's the thing i want to emphasize
when you
put on the board a tactic like this you
should probably be looking for another
tactic to follow
and i see a way that we can simplify the
position and get rid of his
knight because i don't want to allow his
knight to come to e5
and establish itself in the center so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
not h6 check
okay he doesn't even realize that he
could have taken that knight so he goes
king
g7 he's wasting time all right
now the next step a lot of people i know
want to grab this pun but in the spirit
of
how we have played let us instead bring
all of our pieces into the game there's
a couple of things that we can do we can
go c3
but i'm not even gonna worry about that
pawn let's go rookie one
all right if he takes our pawn we're
gonna go rookie seven
and then we're gonna have a queen and a
rook on the seventh rank and that's
a pretty uh difficult
situation for him to deal with uh it it
doesn't matter rook for you one okay
it really doesn't matter rook fee won
okay he won probably the same thing
uh in in that scenario uh now we're
gonna take the pawn to make a little
space
for the rook okay so he's making a very
instructive tactical mistake
i always say the queen is the worst
defender of another piece
all right the queen is the worst
defender another piece because the queen
is very easy to dislodge and we can do
that
note this tactic down rook takes f7
distracting the queen and we're gonna
take his rook
we're basically simplifying we're
winning upon and the rest is going to be
a simple matter of converting an
extra so i want people to understand
that
when i say we don't care about pawns
don't take that
literally in the sense that we never
take free puns
i love pawns just like the next guy over
it's just that you have to put that in
perspective you have to realize when you
go for the material
and when you go for the attack and
people tend to overestimate material
just as a matter of course so here what
we're going to do first of all
is we're going to centralize our queen
in such a position
it's a very good idea to centralize the
queen because we defend c2
the queen is just sort of supervising
the whole board how are we going to
actually win
this game there's a couple of steps the
first step
is to do what what are we
missing in this position what a very
important component
hello let's get this guy involved
right if this guy isn't involved it's
going to be hard to win
let's now the second step is going to be
make luft for the king make some air for
the king
i don't want to have to deal with stupid
back rank threats
uh you know when i'm lifting my rook up
now you might look at this move and say
wait a second
aren't you blocking the rook lift to h3
yes i am but that's not the only rook
lift and
you want to be very careful about
getting fixated on one particular idea
now i'm going to go king g2
and the move king g2 prepares oh what
does it prepare doesn't really prepare
anything i'm just unpinning myself
maybe preparing for although i'd be a
little bit cautious about weakening my
king like this
now in such situations when black kind
of has a bit of a fortress right
everything is protected
how do we actually proceed how do we
soften them up
using pawns is an incredibly good method
of sort of
softening your opponent up right getting
the pieces off of the good squares now
queen a5 makes our job very easy
because what move is now very strong now
f4 is very strong because we're going to
win d6
and we're going to win the game because
now the row comes into d7
and the attack is just unfolding in full
strength
uh the move h4 by the way there was also
good now i want to put the rook on d7
okay fact one
fact two i can't do it immediately so
let's go here first
if he goes queen b7 check we'll just
block with the queen or queen trade is
obviously in
uh very much uh agreeable to us given
that we're up in exchange in two pawns
if he doesn't trade queens he's going to
succumb to this check on d7
so he does how do we win this position
there's many ways of doing it
uh you guys know that uh the fundamental
way of winning a position like this to
create a path spawn identify the pass
pawn you want to create and then create
it
the past spawn that i want to create is
the f pawn right i want to go g4 and f5
because that's where my pawn majority is
no rocket science right it could even
pre-move f5 once we create the
extra pawn of the pass pawn we can use
that pass pawn kind of as a
decoy for black's king black's king is
tied down to the spawn then we bring our
king over and collect the other pawn
and then we promote pawns on the other
side of the board the simplest way of
doing that is actually just to sack the
exchange back
and pick off this fun and the rest is
very simple this is a theoretical end
game
we have actually two pawns it would be
winning even with just the c pawn
and here we can win this just by going
c7
and now could somebody tell now without
the apon c7 would have been a huge
mistake but what do we do here how does
white actually win
how does white actually win here
yeah we need to push that pawn and uh
the rest is going to be whoa the rest is
going to be very simple
don't worry guys hopefully i convince
people that you're in good hands with 13
seconds i'll be able to deliver the
checkmate
i i assume the people saying time have
only just arrived
okay i don't think our opponent is too
happy right now or he's trying to lull
me to sleep
in the meantime i'm going to munch on a
i won't pre-move because
i don't want to risk stalemating him
when you pre-move a sequence of 10-12
moves
there's always a risk that you
accidentally stale stalemate him at the
end
and you certainly don't want that
i don't know i mean the ratings are
refunded i will remind everybody here
100 bits from jrue that's we're talking
about
okay um a reminder that we play three
games at a time
we play three games at a time and then i
will explain each of the three just to
keep things rolling pretty smoothly
let's go on with the next one
and you know 1400s i mean our opponents
are already pretty good
all right this girl let's play another
sicilian
and uh the situation that we have been
playing is the
accelerated all right accelerated dragon
and the idea is we fianchetto the bishop
now he takes on c6
don't first of all i can read lowercase
second of all
um as i said i play three games at a
time and then i go through each game
in detail and answer all questions okay
okay so actually taking on c6 is already
kind of a mistake because
what it does is that it opens the b file
for us
and it also helps us prepare uh the move
d5 so
nick dim thank you for the the prime
could somebody tell me
do we want to trade bishops and if not
how do we
resist the bishop trade here what what
do we do
yeah clearly we don't want to do that
and we do that by developing knight fc
very good
the movie 5 would be very very bad
because it would
weaken the d6 square okay here we go
again with f3
f3 is the kind of move people just kind
of make
but it's incredibly weakening all right
let's castle let's
develop okay bishop c4 walks right into
what move
this walks right into a move that
you guys should be making automatically
which is d5 right
occupying the center cd edcd
and um i assume he's going to drop his
bishop back
i assume he's going to drop his bishop
back and that will lead us to a very
instructive moment now by the way
if he tries to take our knight and then
take our pawn
we don't even have to worry about that
right we'll we can move our rook then
and he won't be able to defend b2 i'll
explain that after the game
um okay bishop d3 that's actually a
better
that's actually a good move um
one sec i'm writing some stuff down okay
what do we want to do in this position
how do we play well our first order of
business right is to prevent him from
castling if we can prevent him from
castling and keep his king in the center
uh we're going to increase our chances
of a
quick attack i'm not sure why people
want queen d6 yeah the move is queen b6
stopping him from castling
now i might not permanently prevent him
from castling but
in the time that he takes trying to get
my queen away from b6
if that makes sense to everybody i am
going to spend that time
expanding in the center so that even if
he manages to castle
which the more i look at this position
is relatively unlikely um
even if he manages to castle he's going
to be dealing with a
hot mess in the center of the board so
that's why ben feingold says never play
f3 there's a reason behind that f3 is
one of the most
weakening moves on the chessboard now
one thing that you want to do when you
look at a position like this is you want
to be very flexible right even though
the queen is preventing him from cast
well never mind queen c1
i'll talk about that afterwards thread
and doof
okay so i mentioned
that we want to spend the time that he
takes trying to pass all
expanding in the center so expanding in
the center what does that mean
what does it mean to expand in the
center the move d4 comes to mind but
take a careful look at this move the
move d4 closes
off the queen's diagonal which helps him
castle
the move is e5 now e5
if he would have taken on e5 we would
have pinned his bishop with devastating
effect
all right it's very clear to me what he
wants to do he wants to go bishop e3
but he's not in time because we are now
ready
to just rampage him in the center let's
go e4
all right this is the beauty also of
this bishop right now we can actually
take with
either the knight or the pawn uh let's
take with the pawn just to preserve
simplicity
uh but we could have actually taken with
the knight that would have been a very
strong move
and um now we have a crushing move
can somebody find for me this question
move yeah
malcolm f tucker is on a roll
the move is knight g4 now how do i see
this move well i see this move because i
see what his threat is what is white's
intention his intention
is clearly to play bishop e3 that's why
he put his queen on c1
so that he can castle so how can we stop
bishop e3 in a way that's conducive to
our attacking aims
particularly noticing that our bishop
if opened uh operates with devastating
effect attacking that b2 pawn
and so we come to the move knight g4
which fulfills all of these
goals at once this is going to be just
absolutely crushing
if h3 then not only can we take on b2
creating an equal or stronger threat
against the queen we can also play queen
f2 check
with mate to follow uh if h3 i would
give the check on f2 and
then play e3 this is where intuition
comes into play right you have to be
okay
with not knowing exactly how you're
going to check mate white here i don't
even see the exact checkmate but i know
it's there
because look at the position i mean look
at white's pieces there's just no way
that this is not going to result either
in checkmate or in grievous loss of
material
and an intuition is the ability to make
that judgment call
and not spend you know two of your three
minutes trying to work out exactly how
the checkmate is going to happen
what do we do here he's gone rocco
funnies prevented queen f2 but let's not
forget about our other set of ideas
let's not forget that sometimes the
simplest way of converting a position
is just to win a bunch of material
that's like life insurance
something goes wrong in the attack
you're still up a rook all right there's
no shame
in taking the time to you know help
yourself to and all you can eat buffet
consisting of white species
all right so
let's see what he does but i'm
anticipating queen d1 bishop a1 and then
he might resign
yeah this is a nice attack i mean
there's nothing we didn't do anything
special we just prevented him from
castling and the rest
sort of followed very naturally
um no this was not pepega at all
actually this was a very sensible idea
that our opponent
came up with in a difficult spot uh so
let's give credit where credit is due
uh but but it's just that he didn't have
enough time to to do it because
the attack was just way too fast uh
e3 here chewie you mean e3 in this
position
e3 maybe he goes bishop c3 i'm actually
not
i'm not sure if that's uh convincing
because e3 blunts the queen we want the
queen to sort of have access to these
squares
right and and the movie three while it
looks very impressive
it's actually uh i guess now it's
obviously still completely winning let's
be clear
uh but i don't know i think it's a
little less convincing and when you see
the chance to win like a full rook
full rook you want to go for it right
even if you think you might see
checkmate
this is the safe option and there's
nothing wrong with that i mean this guy
too is letting his clock run out
is there some sort of conspiracy
yeah apples 95 says e3 after queen d1
again
possible as is knight e3 but why why
bother calculating these variations when
i can just take a full rook and then
worry about e3 or whatnot
yeah these guys are molding pretty hard
indeed
but we're having a good discussion about
the position so
there we go resigned and we are 1300.
okay so one more game and then i will go
through and explain
all three of these games in detail and
1368 so we are facing pretty decent
opposition
he aborts all right great i guess
another one
no it's certainly not a punch let me be
very clear guys letting your clock run
down is entirely within your rights you
can do whatever you want with your time
whatever you want if you want to sit for
five minutes on move three
you can sit for five minutes on move
three right let's distinguish between
the rules
and ethical or unethical behavior so
you know i don't really mind it all
right yara 84.
so again we have e5 and we've played
mostly okay so d5 we have faced once
this is called the elephant
gambit uh it's an oh it's actually not
that bad
uh and i've mentioned this before
these gambits should be taken seriously
they are not
terrible so we're gonna say okay bishop
g4 is
is pretty bad uh now how do we deal with
a move like this because this sets a pin
to the knight and there's a a typical
reaction to this pin that we can sort of
just do
uh and ask him a question that's what my
coach would
say about such a move traveling yeah we
ask him a question what is he going to
do with this bishop because if he plays
bishop h5
then we will always have the possibility
of unpinning ourselves with g4 i don't
want to go g4 immediately that's a
little bit too compromising in the
opening
let's just develop all right knight c3
this protects the pawn of d5 and it
stops the move e4
he plays it anyway but we're gonna take
i suppose he wants to take on
well okay this is a typical mistake
he probably thinks he's winning our
knight uh but
that's just not how it works because we
have what defensive resource here thank
you viking thomas for the tier one
appreciate it
well be careful about the move d3
because the move d3
allows f5 winning the knight
so the move is queen e2 we bring our
heavy hitter onto the e file so that if
he plays f5 which he probably will
stubbornly then we can move our knight
away no yes this would oh no he takes
queen
bishop takes that three now here we want
to be very disciplined about calculation
i know i think i know what most people
are gonna say
which is that we should take with a pawn
but let's look a little bit deeper
alright and this is where we start
violating some of that
some of the sort of principles that
guided us earlier that's how you get
better we're going to take with the
queen
and the reason we're going to take with
the queen is because this pin
is unexploitable the queen on f3 stops
them from playing f5
and we are going to unpin ourselves on
the very next move
and what we're going to do is preserve
the integrity of our kingside pawn
structure which is actually very
important
we could have played gf we're still much
better but i just want to show
that pins aren't always that dangerous
right okay knight f6 he's attacking
r knight on e4 again we
you know the instinct is to play d3 but
what if we wanted to protect the knight
and simultaneously develop our king's
side
bishop d3 but aren't you blocking in the
c1 bishop
isn't that what you told us not to do
well i am but here's the thing it's a
higher priority
to develop the king side right now we
will deal with this bishop we're going
to fianchetto it right we no problem
but right now it's very important to
develop our king's side so that we make
him pay
for keeping his queen on the e file does
that make sense right
it's it's the priorities it's a
hierarchy and that's where chess gets
hard
hopefully you know you know the way i'm
explaining things makes sense so
now we reap the rewards of quickly
developing our king's side because his
king is going to get caught in the
crossfire
all right now he's going to go oh ladies
and gentlemen
no we have some sex he moves here okay
so 97 let's break down exactly
what the drawback of this move is
exactly exactly
no no don't rush
let's be disciplined all right night i
know a lot of people want to throw the
night out but that doesn't do anything
what this move does number one is black
bishop number two it exposes the pawn on
f7 look at this pawn for a second
how can we attack the spawn there's two
ways two ways of attacking pawn
name one of them bishop c4 is one
knight g5 is the other let's go bishop
c4 because if
i know what he will do we have a really
cool idea
that we're going to put on the board if
he plays f6 or if he plays f5
the idea will be the same and it's
actually really cool after f5
let's hope he plays f5 folks let's just
pray that he
okay he's gone f6 now the king on e8
right if you look at it very carefully
it only has one escape square and so
if we take that escape square away
then it's going to be checkmate after gf
knight takes f6 okay it's not like mind
blown
and he allows us to do it so it is a
pretty cool checkmate though
the bishop and the knight working
together taking away the remaining two
squares
from the game um yeah that is pretty
cool
and so we see we won this entire game
without developing our queen side that
is the epitome
of violating some rules in order to
reap the rewards in other ways and i'm
glad
you guys enjoyed it yeah that was nice
of course he set us up for it by the way
had he gone f5 we could have still
taken on f5 with the queen and after
knight takes f5 it may appear that his
king has more space
but where is the checkmate here where is
the checkmate
and in fact the checkmate doesn't change
it's still knight f6 this is a double
check
a discovered double check this literal
strongest track in chess
uh and e7 of course is covered now by
our rook so
d7 and f7 as before are covered by the
knight and the bishop
respectively all right so
he there's just nothing he can do to
defend f7 all right
so this game while we're on it we can
just complete the analysis
just one thing i wanted to make clear uh
in this position right i saw that a lot
of people wanted to go bishop b2
do not be afraid of pins all right some
pins are dangerous
some pins are not here is a good way
of evaluating whether a pin is dangerous
all right
if the pinned piece is defended by a
pawn
generally speaking the pin is not going
to be terribly
dangerous at least in the sense that you
have a couple of moves like
you don't have the burning necessity to
get rid of the pin
if the pinned piece is not protected by
a pawn
then most likely the pin is going to be
a lot more dangerous and you need to
attend to it with a
far greater sense of urgency again this
is very general
here we see that there is a pawn on g2
that's nicely protecting the knight
so we have no need to [ __ ] our
position and give up d5
just to get rid of the pin as quickly as
possible all right that's why i played
the move knight c3
because he's not threatening anything
and by the way
even if we had done something random and
he'd gone e4
this doesn't actually win the night why
not
why doesn't this win the night and this
is a very typical technique now
i i played a pretty bad random move
because as it turns out
uh so there's actually two reasons one
is queenie two counterpinning the pawn
but the main reason is g4 counter
attacking the bishop you'll see this
all the time all the time in a lot of
different openings
where we counter attack the pin piece
precisely in this way or on the other
side of the board
now in this case the funny thing is
black still wins a piece by going queen
e7 it's basically checkmate
you have to give the bishop up but
that's not what i was trying to
illustrate i was just trying to show the
technique
thank you this guy hags and before i go
on i just wanted to take
uh a chance uh to take a second we've
got
2500 viewers and the support today has
been unbelievable as it has been for
days and days and days weeks and weeks
i am honored to have this community so
thank you guys for the support
we are almost at 2500 subs i
would never have imagined that to be the
case so thank you
uh for making my uh job easier uh it's
it's really a pleasure so
just uh again huge huge shout out
to everybody and as i speak i'm
pressuring people bearded hari seldom
with 500 bits
thank you so much and now let's go back
to the
drawing board let's go back to the speed
run
and um i hope i explained the pinning
idea well this is
now people are going to make me blush so
now people are going to make me blush
but thank you thank you
chess tv i think we're on chess tv um
which is which is awesome
okay so uh that's why the pin was not
dangerous we defend it with queen e2
and brad 522 thank you for the prime and
this move queen takes f3
that is like the essence of of what it
means to know the rules so well that you
know when to violate them
this pin is dangerous because the knight
is not defended by a pawn but it just so
turns out
that he can he cannot attack the knight
with a pawn because that square is now
defended by the queen
and then this move bishop d3 right
you're blocking the bishop on c1 what
are you doing
well i am blocking the bishop once but
because he's got his queen and his king
on the same file the absolute top
priority right now is to get a rook to
e1 that is the plan and so we want to do
that as quickly as possible
and so we want to avoid we don't care
about the nice cities we'll take care of
this bishop later
all right i think there is a donate
command um let me just
check oh i thought there uh there should
have been
i don't know uh what the issue is but
there should be a button on my stream i
i don't want to push it into anyone's
face
um in any anyway jayru thank you for the
500 bits
okay uh so on to the first game of
today's
speedrun which is very combative this
was the philidor game and travman 925
here we go
again 4am hype gift and five to the
community six point
fx fighter perakovsky anjesh and acrylic
i'm not on chess to be there simply
organically
2500 viewers i am honored thank you
trav man amazing stuff going on as
always
wow we are on the doorstep of grand
masterdom
in terms of the number of subs so bishop
c4 castles now i wanted to explain
what i meant when i explained that trick
earlier castles there's knight takes c4
and d5 alright and this forks
the bishop and the knight and by
evaporating the center that is obviously
in black's favor right because white's
got more control over the center than
black does
this helps black free himself so
therefore we played bishop b3
in order to prevent uh knight takes c4
this would no longer be a fork
right now our opponent played in a very
sneaky way the move b5
now whenever your opponent is is doing
something like that
expanding on a side of the board you
always want to be careful particularly
in e4
openings when you have the bishop on
this diagonal about
the noah's ark trap or however it's
called uh where the c
pawn advances uh with tempo to c4 traps
the bishop
that is actually a common technique in a
lot of different openings
not only in the philidor but one opening
that comes to mind right off the bat
uh is the ry lopez in the right lopez
there is a line
if white goes d4 i'm just gonna very
quickly make the moves here that's not
important right now
white plays queen takes d4 you can see
the similarities there's a bishop on b3
c5 now it looks like white's fine
because of queen d5 he's attacking the
rook and attacking f7 but black is
already winning a piece here bishop e6
queen c6 check bishop back to d7
queen to d5 white against threatening
checkmate but he's no longer attacking
the rook
and so black plays c4 intercepting the
bishop and trapping it
i think this is called the noah's ark
trap or capoblanca strap so
we can see the parallel here he's gone
b5 he wants to go c5 c4
and most people's response to that would
be let's go a3 let's create a hole for
the bishop
that's fine but my worry with that is
that look at this look at this miserable
bishop i mean
in order to in order to get it out of
the cage you'll have to dynamite
some of these pawns and that's always
dangerous because dynamiting pawns
involves pushing your own pawns
and pushing your own paws and bobs
leaving pieces unprotected so something
like this could happen
all right let's dynamite oh crap the
knight on c3 is unprotected
all right so the way that we decided to
deal with this is actually to bring the
bishop
in front of the potential pawn chain
right
and while we're at it we're also
attacking the rook okay
so if he'd gone rook a7 here we could
have just gone about our business and if
he goes c5
all right our bishop is on d5 perfectly
placed he can take it
but then it'll be replaced by an outpost
knight
okay um so he takes and we talk with the
knight now
i wanted to briefly explain why is it a
good idea also to take with a pawn
all right because to some people i i
understand that this is not intuitive
but the thing is
if you look at the spawn on d5 it
essentially secures a potential outpost
for the knight on c6 and
i understand that the c6 square is
currently protected but
black might develop the desire to
develop his knight once one day and so
knight c6
becomes very much possible and this pawn
just clamps down in black's position
black also can't go c5 because of an
all right clifton beast if c6 then you
can actually
one two defenders and only one sorry one
two attackers one defender
you can just take the pawn with either
your knight or your bishop
and uh you'll just be up upon all right
uh so we decided to take with the knight
because that's an outpost knight f5
and queen g4 is very natural bringing
pieces into the game
and now bishop h6 is a very typical
tactical idea
pinning you know using the pin and our
opponent could have defended by playing
95
and knight g6 basically shielding the
g-file with the nine forcing our bishop
back
and black is actually completely fine
here particularly since our b2 pawn is
hanging but
we took a risk and he did miss uh
that resource deciding to give up the
exchange instead of now the move knight
h6 right
basically forcing the trade of knights
in a tactical way
uh and once that happened he wasted time
taking with his king
we brought our pieces in took a bunch of
pawns and the rest was very simple the
only thing i did that i want people to
notice
centralize the queen bring all the
pieces in create some look for the king
and use the pawns as a battering ram and
that's pieces and as pawns that are
used to dislodge the pieces from their
posts
in order to get to some of these buns
all right now the other way that we
could have done that is like h4 h5 is
also possible i was going to ref i was
going to
actually make this move in order to
soften up that g6 pawn
so that is a technique you'll see very
very often grandmaster games
some i call it softening up right
pushing a pawn out
in order to isolate or weaken or open a
file
uh something like that well i live it
and breathe it
so that is just something that you'll
see
left and right in in top games okay
so any questions about this game
any questions about and of course i'm
not showing the rest of it because it
was really
straightforward and as i said you know
the higher i go
i won't keep repeating the very basics
unless people have a specific question
about it okay
okay once up to 20 yeah well mark's
uh oh you are a sub mark zuckerberg i
was gonna say
if mark zuckerberg wasn't a sub we'd
we'd be in trouble okay
uh so this next game was that nice
attacking game where we played the
accelerated dragon
and then the move knight takes c6 uh
what is an outpost an outpost is
basically like a square deep in your
opponent's territory that is occupied by
a bishop or a knight
generally speaking and supported by a
pawn and it's generally unassailable
thank you smasher
uh oh three eleven for the prime
okay so um this move knight takes c6 is
a very typical
mistake well not a big mistake but it is
a mistake
because after b takes c6 as i explained
d5 becomes easier and essentially
that b file can also be used by our
pieces we actually saw that once we put
a queen on b6 guess what
this file is open precisely because well
i guess we put the queen in front of
the pawn on b7 but you get the point
that b file is kind of important
um i won't delve into the theory here
but basically knight c3 is one of the
main moves
and bishop e3 white basically keeps the
tension
um is dtake c6 passive well d takes c6
isn't so much
passive as it allows the queen trade and
you don't want your king
to have no castling rights uh so so this
is
asking for some trouble black is not in
terrible shape here i mean the king
could find a little square on c7 but
uh we have the chance here to you know
to have a really really strong center
uh and and this move queen b6 is the
crucial move of the whole game stopping
our opponent from castling exploiting
the weakness of the move f3
and then playing very practical right
not bothering ourselves
with a bunch of this tactics just
playing bishop takes b2
and and and winning the rook because we
know that that's winning
we know that that is the simple way to
do it
and uh we don't want to play with fire
when that's not strictly necessary
okay and and the last game we already
looked at so
this was a nice finale for sure but
nothing extraordinary i mean we had the
firepower to do it
and uh you know it's it's always good to
sack the queen no matter in what
position but yeah certainly
ready to do the next set of speedrun
games if you guys are just want to make
sure that
all questions for the most part are
answered what should white have done
here after you stop them castling well
to be to be honest he was already lost
uh in this position
he's already in huge trouble um
i would say that if if i were playing
white i would try to develop my pieces
and i would basically abandon the the
desire to castle
long castle short and i would maybe
prepare castling along
so i'd maybe do something like this and
try to cast a line now castling along
here is definitely dangerous
and by the way d4 trapping the bishop
does it does it drop the bishop
white has a resource here and that's
maybe something that
our opponent missed thank you skating
chocolate for the prime
appreciate it knight c4 you knight c4
counter attacking the queen
and we got a 10 donation from gm no
chance ever superb instruction
thank you for streaming euro friendly
times you're very welcome thank you for
the 10
donation um gm no chance ever so
this opens up this square for the for
the bishop
[Music]
you